I hope you've been enjoying all of our
Disney Princess videos because today
I'll be talking about some of their
siblings but nobody ever seems to talk
about and before we get started you know
the drill like subscribe and let me hear
that Bell button ring for more videos
like this one this Disney Princess has
one of the most siblings that we are
introduced to and she is the one the
only Ariel in 1989 does he brought us
the Amazing Adventures of Ariel but not
before introducing us to her six
gorgeous sisters now I know that the
ages of these sisters are definitely
going to get you guys buzzing in the
comments section because yes it does
contradict itself between the original
Little Mermaid movie and Ariel's
beginning since the latter does focus on
the sisters a lot more than the original
I will be using it to reference the
sisters is from oldest to youngest if
you've been keeping up with us here at
the things you know that we love to
throw some fun facts into the mix now
here's a fact about the seven daughters
of Triton who is the king of the seven
seas according to some theories floating
around the internet the daughters do in
fact each represent one of the Kings
seven seas it also seems like Ariel has
more than just six siblings but I'll get
to that one later in the video just
because you're the oldest Fatima doesn't
mean you get to boss us around at ena is
Ariel eldest sister whose staple look is
an orange seashell bikini top to match
her tail she even wears an iconic
five-pointed tiara just like the one
that her father wears this could be
because she is the eldest of the sisters
and next in line for the throne her
birth name is a variation of the name
Athena just like her mother and it
represents wisdom since she's the eldest
it makes sense that she is the Bering
Sea the largest of all the seven next up
we have Alana who is always seen in her
purple seashell bra and pink seashell
tiara don't look now but dinner explode
on your face it's plankton extract and
sea salt Alana is the only sister rather
than Athena who wears a tiara
unlike Athena though Alana's tiara is a
lot more subtle and resembles her mother
Athena's following the idea that Alana
is second in line to the throne after
Athena
this would make total sense according to
the seven seas theory of the sisters
Alana is the black sea princess Adela is
arguably the most romantic of Ariel six
sisters
what stands out most in Adela is her
intricate hairstyle which she adorns
with a beautiful pearl headpiece looking
back at the TV series Adela is the most
changed mermaid physically the creator
of the series decided to display her a
slightly heavier than the rest of her
sisters either way she still looks just
as adorable with her flirtatious
personality it is no surprise that Adela
is given the only other love interest in
the movie in Ariel's beginning we see
Adela finally land a kiss on her big
crush Stevie she does this in the scene
of Iowa State for this reason Adela
probably represents the Mediterranean
Sea home to many romantic islands
acordes name originates from the Latin
word aqua meaning water she has a
beautiful blue tail with a seashell
brought a match and enjoys writing her
hair up in a ponytail held by some pros
we aren't given too much of an insight
into a Quattro's personality until we
actually see her arguing with Arista for
borrowing too many other things
she is also a self-proclaimed horrible
dancer as we see in a scene where she
refuses all her dance offers until her
sisters convinced her to just let go and
bust some moves in the disney comics a
quater is actually Ariel's eldest sister
instead of a tina and of the seven seas
aquatic is probably the core LT since
she is the most shy and reserved of her
sisters a very old sister service that
has the most prominent features that
distinguish her from the rest of her
sisters it says I see blue eyes so much
with her platinum blonde hair undertale
and seashell bra are a matching shade of
red in Ariel's beginning Arista spice
body is so ditzy sweet and fun excuse me
is that my mask yeah this gorgeous and
stunning mermaid definitely represents
the white sea since her hair is a
platinum white blond
some fans of the movie have theorized
that wrist is name actually comes from
the Arista Records label this would
definitely explain her love for music
for the last but definitely not least
the burial sisters we have be witty and
carefree and Rina and Rina seen
throughout the movie with her pink tail
and brought too much she even keeps her
hair up with a pink little headpiece the
name itself means brave which makes
perfect sense since she is always wrong
Ariel which he's usually getting into
trouble
according to
my Disney the story by an actual name
was simply that it was the name of the
directors I robux instructor nothing too
much cool about the story but it is
definitely still a name with some total
Disney Princess vibes her name and
non-problematic personality makes a
madrina the perfect representation of
the caribbean sea this is where the
story gets a little dark though
according to this same theory Athena the
girls his mother who died when they were
very young represents the Dead Sea I
know guys mind blown now before we get
to the last sibling I want to know if
you guys can guess which see Ariel
represents be sure to let me know in the
comment section and no cheating you guys
have been pretty clever with your
responses so be sure to write it down
with that scrolling before you're done
this young mermaid is only introduced to
us as a young man who is an orphan in
the Little Mermaid TV series his name is
urchin urchin is brave and loyal he
makes an appearance in the fourth
episode of the series soon becoming a
main character following Ariel around
all of her adventures and becoming a non
official member of the mermaid family
he's even seen playing pranks on Arista
attina
and Adela just like a young brother
would the girls even admit that they see
him as their own little brother and that
is all we have for today guys be sure to
hit that subscribe button to become part
of the things family and give this video
a big thumbs up if you're a Little
Mermaid fan I have personally always
loved her a certain thing she is just
absolutely gorgeous but I want to know
who your favorite sister is so be sure
to hit me up in the comment section
below also be on the lookout for what
ciariel represents so don't forget to
hit me up with your answer in the
comment section below and I will be
definitely highlighting the first few
things numbers to get it right see you
guys next time
[Music]
[Music]